and this becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes a chord
with us it just works
sometimes these dishes can become tired
but at lever twists helps make them
fresh again you can't get more classic
than a centuries-old midday meal of
bread cheese and beer reinvented and
marketed by pubs as a plan one's lunch
in the 60s I'm now giving it by 21st
century take Mike Lammers with the most
amazing but super simple beer baked
bread party and full of flavor for a
really quick and easy bread dough sieve
a mix of wholemeal and self-raising
white flour with a good pinch of salt
salt really important the bread
it's the first thing I do once I've
cracked it and smells you want to smell
that salt bake throughout beer in about
250 mils of beer the reason why this
recipe works so well is it the bit got
that yeast so naturally it's gonna work
beautifully give that a really good mix
I'm looking for this mix to be quite wet
if the dough becomes too firm then isn't
a cook dry in the center just as it
starts to fall through the whisk that's
perfect beautiful this mix will work
really well as one large loaf but I want
to make my plan one's a little bit more
special small tins give it that kind of
intimacy and I quite like having my own
little loaf give the moulds are really
nice lining with butter
make sure you butter the top now
tablespoon of flour dust inside the mold
that will stop your mixture sticking tap
out any excess 3/4 fill your little
moulds and we're gonna allow it to sort
of rise just so it comes above the mold
and forms this really nice and miniature
loaf onto the tray centimeter apart into
the oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180
something quite nice about the smell of
home baked breads in the kitchen
delicious no plan was is complete
without pickled onions red onion is a
lot sweeter less harsh than a white
onion the early days of parents
you've got those ghastly sharp pickled
onions that make you almost cry when
you're crunching them on the lightly
pickle my red onion just push your
fingers through so you get these nice
sort of onion rings a little touch of
salt and sprinkle the sugar and then a
couple of cloves in there that gives a
really nice sort of perfume and sort of
makes the pig bloom slightly more mellow
red wine vinegar now Jim got red wine
vinegar white wine vinegar just as good
but red matches the red onion so it goes
hand in glove couple of tablespoons of
vinegar just give that a really good mix
to speed up the pickling process use a
way to put pressure on the onions as the
weight presses down on the onions the
clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work their magic that comes out the
really nice light fragrant pickle
for my 21st century ploughman's I'm
creating an all-in-one salad and
bringing the traditional elements
together with a punchy dressing a
[Music]
tablespoon of English mustard a
tablespoon of honey a touch of salt and
pepper and finish off with white wine
vinegar and olive oil now generally this
sort of three parts oil to one part
vinegar that's the sort of general base
[Music]
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with the plan ones but this is very nice
sort of modern approach to plan once for
my plan one salad I'm using a mixture of
robust and crunchy romaine lettuce and
punchy watercress if I was making a
watercress soup I'd use the stalks
but the stalks are little bit bitter so
I just grab them like that and pinch
them and then twist very peppery very
hot it's so juicy watercress in your
celery chop nice and finally it's the
one thing that every leaves is that
stick of celery so scatter it amongst
the cellars a bit of oomph and color
from some sliced radishes and sweetness
from a thinly sliced apples
whilst you're busy throwing your plan
when salad together do not forget about
your beer bread before it comes out and
the glaze the top a little touch of milk
that will put a really nice finish to
the bread back in for the last five
minutes now for the magic in the plan
once generally you'll see as a ham or
cheddar or Stilton Bauman's it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate ploughman's I'm
adding all three for your cheddar peel
some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar to give them dancing on
top your dressing drizzle browner
circles and then finally our delicious
lightly pickled onions in the good
squeeze and not just dot unions around
bread is ready got that nice yeasty
smell warm crusty and delicious there
you go that is my classic modern version
of a traditional stunning ploughman's
well
my delicious all-in-one ploughman's
salad with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
you